[Music]
greetings apiece welcome to the DS show
and my next guest preacher's son not one
but two literally two of his family
members grew up with both mother and
father son of a preacher and preacher s
here on the D show to tell us his
wonderful story don't go anywhere we'll
be right back
[Music]
this is the doctor Gemma how are you
professor I'm doing well we just had a
little good laugh going there I
mentioned preacher s you know we those
preachers and then I had said for your
mother she was a preacher s actually a
preacher also from the Christian Church
is that right yes yeah so tell us a
little about you so you're your
professor at the UIC University and you
we met one time before when I was
actually there and you got to talking on
the panel and I really enjoyed
interviewing used somewhat and you had
an incredible story and as I started off
not one preacher in the family but two
mother and father and now you're one
who's wishing peace back to me me to you
and your Muslim how did this all come
about well were the people I already
know but for the people now I thought it
was such an incredible story that we had
to share this with the rest of the world
one more time well I was born here in
Chicago I was born in South Side Chicago
I am the oldest of seven at the time
there were four of us my mother and
father had four children and eventually
when I was very young we moved down to
Mississippi my parents were very active
in a Christian Church and there was a
movement to get people to move out of
the cities to move more to rural areas
so we moved down there and both of my
parents were very active in church we
went to church almost every day both of
them used to take turns giving the
sermon they used to preach in church my
father used to ride Christian songs so I
basically just grew up in the church and
I think being a part of the church and
having a lot of time to spend with the
Bible we had to memorize books of the
Bible we did a lot of like study of the
Bible we fasted we observed the Sabbath
all of those things it got me to
thinking about
like what it was that I believe because
my parents are very very big on us
having a belief for ourselves not just
taking it because they they believe in
Christianity so I used to just read I
read a lot and I would read the Old
Testament I read about the prophets in
the Old Testament like Abraham and Noah
and and David and Solomon and peace be
upon them all and it just kind of
occurred to me at a very young age that
the doctrine that they were following
was a lot different than what was
described in the New Testament and so I
think that kind of sparked an interest
to find out why that was mm-hmm so now
what you were being taught for many many
people now they really don't believe
because it's in the natural inclination
of the human being it's intrinsically
built in us just you know to what to
want to worship the Creator now you know
when you come into this whole Trinity
and three gods but one many people they
they're in Nate nature opposes this were
you having that that divide in your life
now we're your parents calling you to
this you're going to the church seeing
this and now there's something described
because so other people can relate also
to that feeling you know that you were
feeling at the time inside your heart
yeah I think as a young young boy the
Trinity never really made sense to me
and I asked my mom about it a couple of
times
I talked to to my friends like in Sunday
school Bible study and really the the
overriding message that we were we were
taught is that it takes a leap of faith
like no one was actually able to really
really explain it to me and so that that
kind of it made me a little bit
uncomfortable because I felt like if
this was something that was going to
determine whether I went to heaven or
hell then I should have some
understanding what it was that I was
actually believing but as a young child
as I said I was living in a very rural
area in Mississippi and eventually we
moved to Louisiana there wasn't a lot of
other options as far as what what one
could believe so all I knew was
Christianity and I just tried to figure
out for myself
what it was that what I was being taught
and how I can reconcile this with the
questions that I had and we say
preachers some people think of the hit
show elite preachers have you heard if
they had money they were [ __ ] with that
so it's not like that what a defined
like when we say preachers what what
kind of what did your parents life
consists of so I mean basically I think
if you would have seen us back then we
might have been considered what I call
holy rollers like my parents were part
of a very conservative Church my mom
didn't wear makeup
she wore long skirts long dresses we
didn't listen to music we actually
didn't have a TV for a number of years I
think four or five years we didn't have
a TV like I mentioned we kept the
Sabbath so on Friday we would turn off
all electrical appliances my mom
wouldn't cook and we would do that from
Friday sundown into Saturday that's as a
Christian yeah as a Christian yeah we
did that my mother sold these garments
for us out of potato sacks and we would
actually pray in those so it wasn't like
a very glamorous type of lifestyle you
know it was very rule you know
working-class type of community small
people knew each other they they
interacted like a very friendly cordial
way sometimes we would travel to
different states to what I call tent
meetings where you have big revival
gatherings but it wasn't like the LA
preachers with the money and the cars
and all those types of things but you
said holy rollers yeah you got high
rollers like the LA preachers but now
you tell my Holy Roller yeah I think
these are people that they they
fervently believe in the Bible they're
they believe in the Bible literally like
it's the Word of God they take advantage
seriously and they try to put it in
practice in their lives and I think
that's what my parents were trying to do
as young adults raising young children
okay we're gonna take a break and we
want to know how you kind of went away
from Christianity and you and ended up
accepting Islam all right yeah yeah
we're gonna we're gonna come back with
this exciting story with dr. Jeremiah
here on the D show don't go anywhere
is there a purpose to our lives do we
simply exist to make a living
[Music]
or were we meant for something greater
something more meaningful
I looked everywhere for answers and I
found Islam
I started my journey
[Music]
have you started yours
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show now dr. Jeremiah
you're a man of academia you know
someone who's prudent wise for you
usually when you go into the
universities they try to just cut out
God all together and you actually that
didn't happen you you you you stuck with
religion not the same religion of your
parents but were you at a point in your
life tempted now to just leave off
religion altogether no I can't I don't
recall ever like having the feeling that
I would not believe in God like I said
my parents are very serious about God
even before like when they were very
young they got married very young there
were certain things that happen in our
lives that like made us believe that
there was God like like for example I
remember when we were living here in
Chicago and we need a new car every
morning my mom would go out to the to
the window say do you see it yet you
know God is gonna bring you guys are
gonna bring it and so we got used to
like reliance on God expecting that the
things that we we obtained were actually
from God and so atheism just never made
sense to me I can never like consider
myself believing that there was no God
but at the same time from a belief
perspective Christianity also didn't
make sense so I think I was looking for
something that like was straightforward
simple easily explained and something
that I can put into practice in my life
do you think a lot of atheists have just
hijacked science they hide behind
science because you know as Muslims
we're very I mean scientific Quran is
not a book of science but it has a lot
of facts about science things that are
verifiable so do you think you see a lot
of people of atheism they hide behind
science they've hijacked it somewhat
maybe to a certain extent but I think
really it it's probably just arrogance
because I think the couple of the few
people that I've talked to that are
atheists it's they kind of have
idea if I can't explain it then it
doesn't make sense if I if I don't have
tools to measure it then it doesn't make
sense and I think that's like just the
height of arrogance there are a lot of
things outside of our experience that we
don't even know we can't detect them and
so we certainly can't explain away
what's happening so I think really it's
arrogant it's also kind of confusion
like I remember my son my oldest son
when he was about four or five he asked
my wife where was she when he was born
and we kind of laughed because you know
she was doing the work on that day and
like we tried to explain to him how it
came about and he just didn't believe it
because he didn't remember that so
that's kind of how I see atheists and I
just if they if they don't have the the
first-hand knowledge of a capability of
measuring or detecting it they just
assume that that phenomenon is not
happening and to me it's just kind of
silly like the same way I look at my son
like you know he was just kind of
inexperienced he was young and now that
he's older he's almost nine and he's
seen pregnant women he's been able to
experience certain types of things
happening and he can see that you know
his mom did birth him similarly the same
way we believe in God
now the we know that the Islamophobia
now you have a lot of racist people out
there and now it's kind of shifted
towards the Muslims and did you see the
same back then was it anywhere near the
level that it is now today no I think
it's much more organized now I think
after 9/11 a lot of us were expecting
that I was a new Muslim but we were
expecting to see this kind of like
coordinated anti-muslim backlash but I
think I think I don't think it really
started until about 2010 I remember the
World Trade Center Mosque controversy
that's where it seemed to really really
pick up and now it seems like there
there's a well coordinated effort they
have a lot of money and they have people
who regularly appear on TV pretty much
just denigrating Muslims for
all kinds of crazy things mhm how do you
I mean have you had experiences with
people who are kind of closed minds and
how do you deal with it when people
recently we had and we get hundreds of
emails people from all over the world
email us and usually we get good
feedback from the program even people
who were very ignorant about Islam
didn't know anything about it they watch
some of the shows and you know what they
they they're they they're false fears
kind of start to diminish okay but just
recently we had a Cathy Smith actually
mm-hm
you know and this was brought to my
attention she really was someone who's
just kind of bringing up things like you
murderess you know making bold
statements you know obviously Aslam has
nothing to do with a lot of these
horrific acts that's you know a fringe
element do but to categorize all Muslims
as murderous terrorists have you ever
come across someone like this and how do
you deal with this if you have I think
probably was more disappointing that I
have people that I'm pretty close to
they're starting to buy into the
rhetoric a little bit and I know how
they were before this these campaigns
started and I know where their
sympathies were so really the when I
first hear it is kind of like shock like
you hear from a family member in that
like all Muslims are terrorists or I've
heard family members say we need to bomb
Mecca and Medinah those kinds of things
are really disappointing so what I try
to do is just highlight the people who
are making these types of claims and
show how before they were making the
same that those camps were making those
same kind of blanket criticisms and
integrations of black people they were
doing the same thing if you go back
further the Jews they do the same thing
to Italians the Irish the Chinese and so
it's the same history of American racism
and bigotry
even though Muslims are not a race same
bigotry and now it's just a Muslim turn
unfortunately mmm so let's continue on
with your story we'll come back to this
so what was it what finally had you you
know accept Islam what was it about
Islam that finally had you
you know coming to it wholeheartedly as
a teenager I was I was young teen a
preteen I was a part of the junior fruit
of Islam so that kind of gave me an
exposure somewhat to Islam but that was
more like a political social type of
organization so I think what finally got
me to Islam as a good friend Hasib he
was a fellow graduate student we were
both studying for PhD in material
science and engineering he went to Egypt
the year prior to study Arabic and I was
always interested in Arabic so whenever
I would ask him how do you say this in
Arabic or how do you write this word in
Arabic he would throw something in there
about Islam so after a few months of
talking with him I asked him how to pray
he showed me how to pray in my office
then a couple of days later I asked him
what do I need to do to become a Muslim
and he was like kind of skeptical so he
told me show up two days from now on the
message it I showed up he wasn't there
but I went and I pronounced the
testimony of faith in April 8 2000 and
since then I've been most humbly left
and that's the same same I always repeat
this over and over for someone who might
be turning in for the first time that
you're declaring that the same way if
you were living during the time of Jesus
you were declared there's nothing where
they worship except the God that Jesus
worship and Jesus if you were living
there at that time he was the Messenger
of God but today Muhammad is the last
and final messenger and I'm not gonna
worship anyone but the Creator one guy
that's it that's it yeah so how was it
in impacted your life since you've that
was how long ago now 14 years 14 years
ago I think the the big the big thing
that that I see a change in and I think
my wife we also talk about this is this
feeling of being connected to this
global community like we have more than
a billion Muslims like many of us are
trying our best to be good people trying
to follow the way of the Prophet and
then being connected to all of those
people all the way back to the prophets
to the prophets before Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him all the way back to
the first prophet this connected chain
of people trying to submit their wills
to Allah so that we can gain the
pleasure of Allah that I think that's
the thing that sometimes
it it takes me aback that God blessed me
to be a part of this community this this
community of Prophet Muhammad we're
gonna take a break and right back with
more with dr. professor Jeremiah here on
the Dean show
[Music]
[Music]
please subscribe to the Biggio follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show professor Jeremiah
now someone like I mentioned earlier you
know somebody who's coming into Islam
I'm sure the person even back then there
were some misconceptions correct so
you're circumspect you're cautious about
what you're getting into
you're prudent you're you looking to
make a wise sound decision your
professor you're an academic you're not
somebody who's fooled easily so you did
your due diligence correct yes so tell
us for somebody out who else is out
there who is also like they tune in to
the deans show maybe they met some
Muslims what advice do you have for
somebody but now that you have all of
this propaganda that's out there against
Islam what advice do you have for people
out there since your people yeah I think
the first thing is take it to the source
like the Koran is the holy book of
Muslims we believe there's no error in
there and if you hear someone side of
verse of Quran and they try to justify
like some criminal type of activity go
and read that verse read through the
verses around it the ones before and
after it and I think most of the time
like you will have no problem seeing the
clear wrong that is being done to the
reputation of Muslims and to the the
word of the Quran and then if in that
case if there's still some issues I
think there are lots of Muslims around
you know not everyone is prepared to
answer questions about the Quran but if
you have a Muslim friend or coworker
ask them questions and if not you can
contact your local mosque or or Islamic
center and there are a lot of there's a
lot of information on the internet I'm a
little bit cautious about suggesting
that people look for information on the
internet because they're like sites that
they trying to look like they're Muslim
sites but they're not but I think the
the main thing is that people have to
challenge themselves to not just take
things the first thing that they hear
like verify information check the
information the Quran can defend itself
like we don't nest we don't have to need
we don't have to defend the Quran the
as capable of defending itself so read
the Quran ask yourself is this actually
what the Quran is saying isn't it
amazing that even with all this false
propaganda against Islam that Islam it
continues to be the fastest growing
religion and more women are entering
Islam than men isn't this amazing it is
it is amazing and actually here in
Chicago we have a lot of white Muslims
what new new white Muslims which to me
is like just amazing because there's a
lot of pressure on white people if you
convert to Islam you've seen it's like
this huge outcast like in
african-american community we've been
more historically more receptive to
Islam but here in Chicago we have a lot
of white brothers and sisters that are
that are embracing Islam and I think
that's because they are those before
they were Muslim they challenge
themselves and they try to see what is
this religion about and if you you look
and you open your heart you can't help
but be convinced one of the other false
misconceptions is that Islam oppresses
women that women have no role in a
society community and recently we had
something on our Facebook page it was a
post about the oldest university that
was in the world that was established by
a Muslim woman fatima in morocco
and then we asked the muslim woman to
come and write and to voice their voices
and they came on by the dozens you know
so many women came on talking about and
these are converse with who have
accepted islam and tell mehat Aslam has
liberated them how they feel this peace
and happiness and this was something is
amazing so have your have your have your
parents have your siblings have your
family members been receptive now to you
it's been a while a long time now but
now that they've seen your character
improve you obviously become a better
human being how's their attitude towards
Islam and you've been my family has
always been positive um my immediate
family has always been positive my
parents my siblings I haven't had any
negative reaction from any of my family
actually when I told my family
that I converted to Islam a lot of my
friends were like ok who's surprised
about that no they were just expecting
it to happen so no way I haven't had any
negative negative responses from my
family but one thing that I have noticed
is that my family is there they they
tend to take up my immediate family they
will take up for Muslims even when we're
not there like if if there's a
conversation with someone else they will
defend the Muslims and I think that's
because we've tried to maintain good
relationships and that's something that
is encouraged in Islam that's
emphasizing Islam did I ask you a
question yes I'd like I lost them tell
me tell me when I was there at the
University there was a gentleman who was
in the audience and I had asked him if
he was because he was really inclined
towards Islam okay now I have your proof
can I go back yeah go ahead
so I think I think it's clear that Islam
does not oppress women
Islam is a way of life and if you look
into the rules of Islam the rulings of
Islam then definitely they that's
they're there for like a sound healthy
society and I think what we need to be
careful as Muslims is that we don't use
our own personal insecurities to defame
the quote/unquote image of Islam so
there are some people amongst us mostly
men they might take some liberties that
are not theirs but Islam doesn't give
them that yeah like Islam doesn't give
Muslim men the right to oppress Muslim
women and I think you see that when you
talk to Muslim women that the ones that
know the religion that have studied
their religion they will say this is not
from the religion so if there is some
negative thing it's from people and
people will find something to justify
whatever they're doing whether it's
Islam Christianity Judaism or whatever
now how can if this is Fatima who
established the first look the oldest
university in the world now this is by a
Muslim woman when now the women in this
country didn't
those rights to some what you know
there's still fighting for rights but
I'm talking about this was an 8 in the
1800s and we're talking about this was
back in 8 in an 8th century so I mean
when you just study a little bit of the
history and you take off those blinders
yeah
and I consider myself a beneficiary of
that legacy personally my teacher and
like the person that taught us like how
the practice Islam the the rules of
faith he graduated from that institution
he's now an instructor at Zaytuna in in
California so I'm thankful may Allah
bless her for her sacrifice that really
that's just a five on to me yeah amazing
yeah so a thousand years later we're
still benefitting good luck tell us sir
before we cut out there was a Latino
brother who was in the audience we asked
him if he wanted to accept Islam he was
inclined towards it at that time he did
we got word that he actually accepted
Islam do you know the brother yes I do
he did tell us a little bit about him I
don't know him very well but he he I
really liked the approach that he was
taking he was being very mindful he
wasn't like interesting and just rushing
into something based off emotion he
asked very good questions he made good
friendships with Muslims and he actually
observed the character of the Muslims
first which i think is important he got
a chance to be around the Muslim I think
that's really what convinced him in the
end because a lot of times people are
convinced about Islam but they don't
know what their life is gonna be like
they don't know like how am I gonna have
friends will I have to change how
address of the food that I eat and once
he saw that people accepted as he was
that his belief system was gonna was
gonna change and the rest was up to him
I think he was he was comfortable and he
became and became Muslim one who submits
to the will of the Creator not the
Christian thank you we're out of time
professor dr. Gemini thank you so much
for being with us thank you thank you
God Almighty for your peace be on to you
and that was the son of the preacher and
preacher has two preaches accepted his
way of life by the way Muslims love
Jesus and no Muslim is a Muslim unless
he believes or she believes in Jesus as
a mighty messenger and this is the
simple belief
a Muslim believes in and all the
messages of God and we submit only to
God and Islam is a beautiful way of life
that is practiced by over 1.7 billion
people in the world
one out of every four people is a Muslim
we have a book a believable book a
believable message and we have facts in
it not fiction so if you'd like to pick
up the Koran call us at 1-866-376-8255
us and every week we're here with a new
exciting show we'll see you next time
God willing until then peace be with you